alright guys welcome to this Python game
development video series and we'll be
using the famous spy game library of
Python to create the school space
invader game and we are going to go
really in depth into this spy game and
learn about a lot different concepts and
specifically we will be learning a lot
about like new parts of Python that you
haven't explored yet and new parts of my
game like moving characters shooting
bullets and understanding game concepts
like game loops and stuff like that so
if you haven't ever created a game or
you have only created a very basic game
this would be a very good starting point
for you guys so before we get started on
all of that cool stuff learning about
game development and stuff like that you
should make sure that the basic stuff is
installed so first basic stuff is
obviously Python so Python is not
installed if you are using Python for
the first time just go to python.org and
then click on downloads and just
download the latest version of python
after downloading python we are going to
be using ide which is basically a cooler
way to write code of Python so I'm going
to be using PyCharm and if you don't
want to buy the professional version
although you have a 30-day trial which
you can use for this course but if you
don't want to buy it just download the
community version which is free and you
won't need more than the community
version but if you are using something
like sublime text or maybe the main
Python terminal that's also fine it
won't matter but if you want to follow
along completely make sure that you
download pycharm and thirdly you can
just have a look at the PI game website
that we are going to be using to create
our game so you can just have a look at
it it's not really necessary but really
just have a look at what has been done
with this PI game and look at the games
maybe and you know just kind of get
ideas so let's get started a make sure
that you have downloaded pycharm after
you have downloaded PyCharm it will look
somewhat like this now that we have
everything installed we need to make
sure that we have this new project over
here so for that just go to file click
on new project and then write down the
project name over here I've already
created the project and I'm calling it
space invader because this is the game
that we'll be creating and probably
you've already played this game when you
are
but the main idea is that there is a
ship at the bottom and it's going to hit
the enemies that are at the top by
shooting a bullet and every time you hit
an enemy your point increases and the
enemies slowly come down if it touches
the spaceship you lose and the final
score is what how many enemies you have
shot so that's the basic idea of the
game but you'll understand more as we go
through the videos so after you have
created this project we are going to
create a new file over here I'm just
gonna call it main because most of our
code is going to go inside this main dot
Python file and after that we need to
install my game so if you are using
terminal you can just open up your
terminal by typing in CMD and you can
just type in pip install by game and
this is for people who are not using
pycharm or you are using something else
like sublime text or python terminal but
if you're using pycharm what you would
do is you would go to file and then you
would go to settings and in settings you
would go to project name whatever name
you have given if you wanna follow along
call it space invader and then go to
project onto Plato and over there you
can see I have already installed my game
and if the spy game is not already
installed just go to this plus sign over
here and search for my game this is my
game and then you can select it and
click on the install package and this
will install PI game onto your computer
now I've already installed PI games so I
am NOT going to install it again and
after that you can just type in by
import PI game and if this doesn't show
an error that means that PI game is
installed on your computer so that is
this is pretty much it this was a pretty
small video just an introduction video
we are going to be doing a lot of cool
stuff from the next video we are going
to be creating our game we are not going
to go into theory and stuff we're just
going to start with practical stuff and
actually start creating our game so we
are going to be creating a game window
next time so as you can see this Python
has a window right now so we are going
to be creating this kind of a window in
the next video with the cross button
over here so I'll see you over there
and this to recap what we did in the
last video was installed by game and in
this video we are going to be creating
our first Python game window using PI
game so obviously the first thing we
need to do is import my game into our
program and hopefully you have already
created this mean dot PI file if you
haven't just created right now and first
of all we are going to import my game
and then we need to initialize PI name
to access all of the code methods and
all of the other stuff that is inside
the spy game module so to initialize
this I gave module what we need to do is
just type in my game dot in it so
whenever from now on to create a game or
create a new game just make sure you add
this line otherwise your Python or eye
game code is not going to work so let me
just add a little bit of commit over
here saying initialize the PI game
alright so after initialization we have
to create our screen and PI game makes
it really really easy it's just one line
of code it's crazy so he is going to
write screen and this is our available
and we can just try it by game and this
is to access the methods that are inside
the spy game module and need to access
the display dot set mode method and then
inside these brackets we need to add
another bracket so this is a tuple make
sure you add another bracket inside it
otherwise it's not going to work and
people mess up over here and then ask
why is it not working it's because we
haven't added another bracket over here
and then inside it is going to take in
two values the height and the width of
the window that you want to create so
I'm just going to give it for now a
value of 800 pixels of height and 600
pixels of width so this should be good
and let me just add a comment create the
screen and let me just format this
properly so this is all you need to
create a screen but as you'll see after
we run this program that it has one mean
that thing about it so as you can see
the game window was created but after a
few seconds is just went away let me
show it to you guys again so after we
click on play it stays there for like
one or two seconds then it goes away and
this is because our Python program
goes through these three lines and then
just exits the program and therefore you
can't see that screen for a long time
because it just takes one or two seconds
for this program to run and that's it
so one way to bypass that is just create
an infinite loop over here and this also
has problems but just to show you guys
that it works I'm gonna do it and I'm
gonna make sure that my task manager is
open because this will hand my computer
so make sure that your task manager is
also open because this will hang the
window at least that you're working on
but just to show you guys I'm gonna run
this and you'll be able to see that the
window is there but it is totally hand
so you can see the window is there but
it's nothing is working over here and
this cross button is not working let me
just go back over here and close my eyes
on window click on end task and it has
been closed now why is it hanging why is
it not just closing down by pressing
this cross button it is because we don't
have an event of a quit function over
here so there is no way to quit the
program our program is just inside this
while loop and it's never able to end
and windows make sure that that program
gets hand that's why we need to add a
quit functionality to our eye game key
window just like this window has on
pressing this close button this window
closes so for that we are going to be
using something known as events now
we'll get into events more a little bit
later but for right now just understand
that event is anything that is happening
inside your game window my game window I
just mean a window inside which your
game is being played so anything
happening inside that game window is
basically an event so for example if you
press arrow keys or anything on your
keyboard you move your mouse that is an
event and even when you press this close
button that is also an event in my game
so this pressing of the close button is
actually known as a quit event in I game
so we are going to make sure that we
exit this loop when this close button is
pressed so for that what we are going to
do is you're gonna create a variable
let's call it running and we are going
to give it a value of true and inside
this while loop we are instead of just
typing in file
true to make it an infinite loop we also
know call it by running
and whenever we want to break outside of
this infinite loop we're just gonna turn
the variable of running into false and
it will automatically break this while
loop so if you don't know the basics of
Python or programming basically while
true runs infinitely and then this value
of 2 is tuned to false it comes out on
the while loop but you're not going to
go into much into that because that's
just like very basic programming so
anyways after writing while running what
we need to do is go through the list of
events that are happening inside our
game window so for that we are going to
create a for loop and create a variable
event and then they are going to loop
through all of the events that are
happening inside our game window how do
you do that my game makes it really easy
just type in my game dot event dot get
and then brackets and this makes sure
that all of the events that are there
that are happening get into this eye
game dot event dot get and then we can
loop all of these events using the for
loop and one by one check if this cross
button has been pressed and then I'll
tell about this cross button is being
pressed we just turn this loop into
false so this is pretty easy so inside
this for event we're gonna check if the
close button has been pressed and how do
you do that this type in if event dot
type equal equals two and then we are
going to check whether the event in my
game is quit or not if it's quit then we
are gonna change the value of running
into false so this is pretty easy so we
have changed our value of true into
false
whenever the close button is being
pressed and this close button is
basically a quit event and we are going
to loop through all of the events to
find this quit event so we will go into
more into events a little bit later but
for right now this understand this is
what we are doing so let's just play
this and understand whether it's working
or not let's see so right now you can
see that video system is not initialized
is giving us an error it's a spy game
dot event dot get all right so the
problem is that we have misspelled this
it's not my game dot small letter
squared it's just by game dot quit and
that's pretty much it so when you are
dealing with a lot of syntax you have to
make sure
one but small problem click on plate and
now you can see that this is working and
a window is not going anywhere the
computer is not hanging it's looking
pretty good
alright guys let me just go through this
once more what we are doing over here so
we have created our screen we have
initialized our PI game and then over
here we have created our game loop so
let's actually call it the game loop
over here we're just gonna add a comment
which says game loop so this is an
infinite loop which makes sure that the
game is running always and the window
doesn't close thumb and we know we want
to do something like move a bullet or
move a player or something like that
move a human being inside our game
window we have to make sure that we do
stuff inside this wild infinite loop
which only exits when this close button
is pressed and we have implemented that
close functionality over here by
pressing by getting the events all of
the events using this PI game dot event
dot gate method and then we are looping
through all of the events so if more
events are added for example if somebody
presses an arrow key to move forward
that is also going to be looped in this
eye game dot event dot weird loop and
then we can add another condition that
if I hope he is pressed move that player
but more of that in the future for right
now this understand we look that if
event dot type equals to 5 m dot quit
and then we change the running into
false to make sure that we come out of
this while loop and I know guys I am
repeating a lot of stuff right now but
this is like the basics of game
development so I want to make sure that
you guys understand it properly
anyways guys this is pretty much it for
this video in the next video we are
going to change the title and add some
stuff into our game window so I really
look forward to that so right now it is
just black and it's just saying I again
window it's not cool so we are going to
look into that in the next video I'll
see you over there
so in the last video we learn how to
create this game window using pi game so
this window is a little bit not
personalized because it says buy a game
window over here the background is weird
the logo is not there so in this video
we are going to be learning about three
main things the first thing is how to
change the caption of this window
instead of Pi game window will make it
something say something like space
invaders we are going to learn how to
change the logo of this window right now
it's like a snake or a turtle or
something like that and how to change
the background color of this window now
these three things are very basic but
obviously very important when you are
creating a game so let's get starting on
that and first thing we're gonna do is
obviously just comment that so that you
guys can come back to this code and look
what's happening so we're gonna write a
comment title an icon and after that we
are going to change the caption or the
title of our window and my game makes it
very very easy you just write in my game
dot display because we are meddling with
the display of our windows so we have to
write in dot display and then dot set
underscore caption and then it requires
the title of the window we'll just call
it space invaders because that is what
we are creating and then we are going to
create the image so you must have been
seeing this UFO dot PNG image over here
we are going to be using this image in
just a second I'm going to show you how
you can get this image but before that
let me just add this icon inside our
program so for that this is also very
easy first of all what you can do if you
want to get the same image is that you
can go to this web site known as flat
icon calm and then search for spaceships
or any kind of icons so I have searched
for spaceship and I got this cute UFO
icon so to download this you can just
click on download collection and make
sure that you select PNG and then 32 by
32 pixels size so whenever you are
working with an icon and pie game make
sure you select the 32 into 32 I haven't
experimented with 24 or 16 pixels it
might work but hand is going to go with
32 into 32 pixels you can select any
other icon if you want so I selected
this icon and
is downloaded it into my project and
here is UFO dot PNG now to add this
insight our Python program it's pretty
easy you just type in icon equals to PI
game dot image because you are using an
image so we are going to be using the
image module that is inside pi game and
then dot node we want the image to load
and then we just write the name of the
image so in my case it's UFO dot PNG so
we are going to use that you have four
dot PNG and then the next line is pretty
simple we are going to use this same dot
display that we did with the title I'm
just going to write that over here and
then just said it's not showing but I
think it's said underscore icon so you
can use that and then you just type in
the variable name of I can over here
that we have created and this will make
sure that the icon has been added so
let's just run this and see if it's
working or not so as you can see the
icon is also working and the Space
Invaders is this so this is looking
pretty good we have learned how to add
an image not exactly an image just icon
over here and change the title window so
this is looking pretty good
the third thing we need to learn is how
to change the look or the background of
our window so for that we need to use
something known as screen dot fill so we
are gonna go inside our while running
loop and over here we are going to write
screen so anything that you want to be
persistent inside our game window that
you want to make sure that appears
continuously it can be an image or it
can be some text it has to go inside
this running infinite wire loop that is
why we are going to change the color
inside this running infinite while loop
so we're gonna just write screen dot
fill and then inside this we are going
to create a tuple make sure you add
another bracket inside this so there are
two brackets and then you give it three
values of RGB so we are going to give it
I'm going to explain what RGB is in just
a second I'm just going to give it a
value of zero
right now so just to understand this RGB
means is red green blue and basically
every color in this world is made up of
these three values and one more you can
say opacity but let's not go into that
so RGB basically stands for red green
and blue and this is the values these
are three values that you can use to
basically implement any color on the
screen so this makes shirt and this
value goes from zero to 255 so you can
make it 255 but not more than that and
you can use it in a combination so let's
say we want just a pure red color so we
will say red P 1 255 and then green zero
and blue zero and similarly if you just
want a green color we can say 0 255 and
blue zero now what if we wanted a light
light green color we can lower down this
value to maybe like 150 so this will be
a lighter version of pure green so this
is how it works basically and just to
show you guys a more better version of
RGB or what you can do with RGB if you
haven't understood it properly let's go
to Google and you can just type in color
to RGB and go to any website where I am
just going to go to this rapper tables
website and over here you can see these
RGB values so obviously I told you read
is 255 0 0 line is 255 0 G this and
similarly and so on so let's go with
this red color right now and you can
choose any values and there are lot more
colors you can even make your own colors
by trying out different three values so
just experiment with it
a little bit so I'm going to just choose
the red color so we are going to go back
to our code and I'm going to write down
to 55 but this is not going to work even
though we are trying it but this is not
going to work just telling you in
advance so you can see that it's not
working it's just a black screen so over
here we need to use something known as
update so right now our display is not
updating so that's why PI game provides
a method known as display update to make
sure that if we add anything inside our
display window it gets updated inside
this while running Lu
before that is pretty easy just make
sure that you add it after every game so
it's spy game dot display so let's just
try display dot update and that's it so
we have to add a couple of lines inside
your pipe Python game code the first
line is this init line and obviously you
need to make a screen but two lines that
are always going to be there is this
init line and the second line that's
always going to be there is this update
line because you want to update your
screen because your players is going to
move the bullets are going to be moving
the ami is going to move moving the
score is going to be changing so you
want to make sure that your display is
always updating and by display I just
mean the game window that we are working
on for this program it means this screen
variable so anyways so now we have a
Britta date let's give it a shot let's
click on play and as you can see now
it's in red color so it looks good we
have changed the title we have changed
the logo and our screen is updating to
red I don't like red I just wanted to
show you guys that you can change the
color and maybe we'll change to
something a little bit more funky in the
later videos right now I'm just going to
go with black that is zero zero zero and
that's pretty much it
so guys I'll see you in the next video
where we are going to be finally adding
images and our player that is maybe a
spaceship some kind inside our game
window and so I'll see you there where
we are going to learn how to add images
inside our game so piece up
so the last video we learned how to add
a caption and a logo and how to change
the background screen of our game window
in this video we are going to learn how
to add an image to our game window which
is pretty cool and pretty easy because
of my game but first of all let's look
at the player PNG which we are going to
add inside the game window which is kind
of a spaceship which is shooting being
sort of its amps so if you want this
image you can just go to flag icon comm
and download this image obviously you
can use any other image you want but I'm
just gonna stick with this image and you
can go to download collection and
obviously search for arcade space over
here if you want this exact image and
then choose PNG and choose a 64 by 64
pixel obviously you can resize it in PI
game but I have seen that it's better if
you already get the image of the size
that you want in this case I want a 60
64 by 64 pixel version so I'm going to
take that and I've already added it to
my project over here so after you have
done that over here then you can come
back and we can start adding the image
but before we even start that I just
want to discuss what is this 800 and 600
I have put over here I wanted to discuss
this but this 800 is the width and the
600 is the height I think I might have
said something wrong about this in the
starting videos this 800 is actually the
width and not the height and the 600 is
the height so if you look at our window
this is the x-axis you can think of this
window as an X and y-axis window so if
we go from left to right this is an X
axis and if we could go from top to
bottom this is a Y axis so it always
starts from 0 comma 0 which is at the
top left corner and then we as we go on
the right-hand side the x-value starts
to increase and on this top right corner
the x-value is 800 because that stands
for width and now if we go from top to
bottom the value of Y increases while
the x value remains the same so over
here the value is 600 but the value of x
is 0 so if you don't understand it a lot
don't worry about it just think of it as
this left left to right is basic
X and the value right now of this whole
window is 800 in terms of its width and
the value from top to bottom is 600 and
the value at the bottom is 600 and if
you want to go and do into the middle
it's approximately 300 not approximately
if it's exactly X 300 so why I'm telling
you this because we want to place our
image in a particular position so that's
why we need to give it exact coordinates
obviously you can experiment with
coordinates a little bit but you go into
it so let me just add a comment over
here so that we know that we are talking
about the player and then we need to add
the player image which is pretty easy
like we have done it in the terms of the
logo so let's just copy and paste this
over here and change so you have four
two player dot PNG and then we are going
to give it the X and y axis where you
want the image to be positioned so let's
create two more variables let's call
this player X and we are going to give
it the value of 370 and I'm going to go
into why we give these values to player
X and player Y so these variables
basically represents the coordinates
that we want and over this we are going
to give the Y the value of 480 so why
have we done that so if we look at this
window we want the player image to
appear somewhere over here which is
exactly the half of the screen width so
we wanted to appear at the starting of
the game at least we wanted to appear in
the middle and we wanted to appear in
the lower half of this window so the
y-axis should be closer to 600 because
this point is 600 if you guys remember
this lower part so you want it to appear
a little bit above it so we can give it
a value of about 480 or 450 whatever you
guys want and then the x value we are
giving it 370 which is a little bit half
less than half of the width so the width
is 800 and if we go a little bit less
than this this is 370 because we have to
consider the size of the image itself if
we give it exactly the value of 400 then
it's not going to fit perfectly that's
why we have given these
values so you can see that the 370 is
somewhat half of 800 and this 480 is
close to 600 obviously when we change
the values you will understand this
concept a little better and feel free to
change these values and see the effect
it has now after this we are just going
to create our function and we are going
to call it player now I'm going to go
into why we are creating a function but
let's just create the function for now
and then we are going to use a width
method known as screen dot lit so it
basically means to draw so we are
drawing an image of player on to our
screen and this screen is actually known
as the surface of our game
we will go into what it as a surface
Alvis later I know I'm saying that a lot
but it's not relevant to this video but
just understand that we are drawing this
image of player dot PNG on our game
window by using this method known as dot
blade and dot blade blade actually means
to draw so we after loading the image
you also need to draw it on the screen
so that's why we are using this green
dot plate method and over here it
requires two parameters or values the
first value is of the image itself so we
are going to give it image and the
second thing it requires are the
coordinates so we are gonna give it the
coordinates of player X and player Y so
the x and y coordinates after this we
are going to call it I'm just gonna ask
you guys a question where do you think
we should call this player we want this
player to appear in every frame of the
screen we don't ever want this player to
disappear if you guys said inside this
while loop
you guys are correct so we are gonna
call this player method inside over here
so let's just call it and we are going
to just call it over here like this and
make sure that this player method is
called after this green dot fill method
of otherwise this player won't appear on
the screen why do you think that is this
is because the screen is drawn first and
then on top of the screen we draw a
player or a spaceship if the opposite
was true then the spaceship would be
drawn underneath the skin the screen not
the skin but then it will be drawn
underneath the screen so that is why we
all
wanted to be drawn after screen dot fill
actually let's change let's remove this
position to from there to over here
somewhere so that we guys know where
this so because we are going to be
adding a lot of images and stuff that's
why we need to make sure that this
screen dot fill is just above everything
and all the other things aren't drawn on
top of the screen alright guys so this
is pretty much it let me just add
another comment I don't know where it
disappeared this standard for RGB and
red green blue just to make sure that
you guys are still remember what this is
all right so this is looking pretty good
and our player should appear on the
screen so let's run it and then we'll
just go through all of this stuff again
to see what is happening alright so as
you can see our image has appeared on
the screen so first we loaded the image
in this plain image variable we pointed
out the X and y values and the x and y
values were dependent on the screen size
that we gave over here 800 and 600
because we wanted it to appear in the
let me just close this one the old one
all right and because we wanted it to
appear in the middle that is why we gave
it the value of approximately half of
the screen so for example if I gave it
the value of let's say just to
experiment let's say we gave it the
value of let's say 750 that is close to
right hand side and we reloaded it and
as you can see it appeared on the right
hand side so you can see that the x
value has increased and similarly if we
decrease it to let's say about 30 I'm
just showing you this to you guys so
that you guys can understand the X&Y
positions clearly you can see that it
appears on the left hand side so let's
change it to back to about 370 and
similarly in Y if we change this to
maybe 30 you will see that it appears on
top of the screen instead of at the
bottom of the screen so as we get go
down we are getting closer to that 600
value so we are going to from 0 to 600
so let's change it back to 480 and
hopefully now you guys have understood
properly the meaning on
x and y-axes so anyways after that we
created this function known as player
and inscribe that we drew this image
onto the screen and it required two
values the image the x and y coordinates
and then to make sure that this player
is always shown on the screen we added
it to this wild game loop infinite loop
so guys this is pretty much it for this
video I might be repeating a lot of
things a lot of times so it might be a
little bit irritating for some guys but
hopefully you guys understood it
properly in the next video we are going
to learn how to move this layer from
left hand side to right hand side using
our arrow keys on a keyboard so that's
going to be really exciting let's wait
for that so I see in the next video
peace out
in the last video we learned how to add
an image inside our game window in this
video we are going to learn how to move
this image left right or top or bottom
so basically we are concerned about the
movement of an object inside our game
window or anything that we draw it can
be image it can be an of text after you
watch this video you will understand how
the mechanics of movement in a game
works so just to make sure that you guys
understand it I have created an image so
that you guys can understand what we are
going to do and the basics of movement
of an image or anything that you want so
obviously we have created a game window
this is our game window it is 800 wide
that is 800 x-axis and then it's 600 is
height that is you can see it of this as
Y axis and our spaceship currently is at
370 pixels as we have added this over
here that is the player X is at 370
pixels now if we go back to our image
what if we wanted this image to move
from over here to over here we can this
add five pixels to our already existing
370 pixels and this image will move in
the right hand direction and now what if
we added five pixel continuously so this
5 pixel will if we added continuously
this image will continue to move towards
the right-hand side so for example we
can add a functionality which adds 5
pixels to our existing 370 pixels in a
while loop some kind of a while loop and
this will happen continuously after
every iteration of lu similarly if you
want to move it to the left hand side we
can just decrease some value from a 370
pixel value that is we can decrease some
ex-player x value and will move towards
the left hand side and similarly if you
want to move up we can subtract some Y
value so currently the Y value of this
is 480 so if we subtract some value from
this 480 it will move towards up
direction and if we add some value it
will move in the downward direction so
adding and subtracting values from x and
y coordinates of a current position of
the
or in this case spaceship can lead to a
movement of that object and we have to
add it to a while loop because we wanted
to happen continuously so if you go back
to our code we need to add one thing
before I can show you guys how we can
add values to our player X and player by
or we how we can subtract it so before
that we need to make some changes
because currently there is no way to
manipulate the X&Y coordinates from our
while running glue and if you didn't
understand what I meant by this over
here don't worry about it when we
actually write the code you'll
understand what is happening and what I
mean by increasing the x value to move
it towards the right hand direction
basically if you move it to very very
quickly it won't seem that the image is
moving it will just seem like that the
spaceship is continuously moving because
of the effect of persistence in AI we
can't see things that are happening very
very quickly like magicians do they
create illusions by moving things really
quickly and the persistence in the eye
tells us that the image hasn't been
erased and then created over here it
just assumes that the image has moved on
the right hand direction if you are
adding the v value to our already
existing x-coordinate so anyways we need
to do something so that we can
manipulate the value of player X and
player Y from the running while loop so
what we can do is go to this deaf player
function and over here add X comma Y so
that we can send in the values of the
new X&Y coordinates that we want and
then instead of player X and play arrive
can just add x and y so that the values
that we sent to this player instead of
the the last values that it got from
player X and player Y instead of that
the new values that we send in of x and
y are being shown on the screen or being
drawn on the screen so now we have to go
back to the place where we are calling
this function so over here right now
let's just write in player X and player
Y and you will see that there has been
no change so let me just exit this first
and then play it again let's play it so
you'll see that there has been no change
because you are not manipulating the
player X and player by
right now so let's go through this once
as to what's happening over here so
first it goes to this code it creates
the spaceship then it takes the
coordinates of the x and y of your
player or the spaceship and then there
is this player exchange let me remove
this right now we don't need it and then
if we go down we have created this
function of player X comma Y and then
this is being drawn on the screen so
this code hasn't been executed yet
because it is inside this one while
running loop but the program just sees
that this exists now when we go down
over here then this player thing is
called and it takes the player X and
player Y value from here and sends it to
this deaf player function and inside x
and y currently the 370 and 480 exists
so this image is being drawn at this
coordinate now what if we change the
value inside a while running functions
so for example let's say we increase the
value of player X by something small
this lets this increase continuously by
5 so this will move really really
quickly and you won't be able to see the
image moving towards the right-hand side
but I just want to show it to you guys
for the speed so you can see how quickly
it moved I hope you call it just to slow
it down I'm just gonna give it the value
of 0.1 so that you guys can see properly
and you will see that it is moving in
the right hand side direction slowly so
why is this happening so every time this
while loop is running the player
x-coordinate increases by 0.1 and this
value is said over here in this function
player function and then it is sent to
this new player function and the new
image is basically drawn on a new
coordinate and the original image is
being removed
so what example let's also just let's
make it zero point two and this time we
are also going to print out the value of
player x so that you guys can see that
the player x value is increasing from
our original value so here you can see
that being increased by zero point one
and it's going on let's stop it right
now and let's actually try it to move it
in the left hand on left hand side
so let's give it a - value of 0.1 so now
we want to decrease the value so instead
of increasing the value we want to
decrease the value and move it towards
the left hand side so let's play it
again this time and hopefully let's just
remove the player of the print function
because we don't need it
so now let's play it and you can see
it's moving towards the left hand side
and similarly if we do instead of the
x-coordinate we do the y-coordinate and
decrease this value is gonna go towards
the up direction so let's reload it
and you will be able to see that it's
moving towards the up direction and
similarly if we add stuff it was going
to go down so FLE you guys understood
the mechanics of a movement of an object
just to reiterate why is this movement
happening why is when when we are
decreasing the value in Y it's going up
so because at the bottom the value of y
coordinate is 600 so if we decrease the
value it is going up so over here it's
about 480 and if we decrease it more
it's gonna go to us up direction and
similarly if we increase it it's going
to go below more than 600 coordinates so
right now you can see there are some
some fallacies with this system right
now we can't control where this is going
and you'll be able to see that it just
goes outside the screen so we need to do
a couple of things first we need to make
sure that we can control this movement
of the spaceship in the left and the
right hand direction using our arrow
keys on the keyboard and the second
thing we need to do is add a boundary so
that the spaceship doesn't go beyond our
game window right now it's just
disappearing by going outside the game
window so we'll be handling these two
things in the next and the coming video
so in the next video we are going to
learn how to add keyboard support to our
game so basically we are going to
control our spaceship using arrow keys
and that's going to be really exciting
so I'll see you in the next video this
is pretty much it for this
and the last video we learn about the
movement mechanics of the objects in our
game window so for example if you do
player y equals to minus equals to 0.1
then it will move in the up direction so
if I run this man you can see that a
spacious is moving in upward direction
but right now we don't have any way to
control this spaceship we can't control
it using a keyboard and this is exactly
what we'll be learning in this video so
what we'll be doing is that when we
press a left arrow key on a keyboard the
spaceship is going to move towards the
left hand side and when we place a right
hand side arrow key then a spaceship is
going to move on the red right hand side
so what is the algorithm to do that so
first of all we are going to check
whether any each stroke is being pressed
on our keyboard and after we checked
that we are gonna have check whether the
keystroke pressed is either left-hand
side arrow key or the right-hand side
arrow key so we are going to do that so
let me just write down an if condition
let me just remove this over here we
don't need it so after that let me just
tell you one more thing so any keystroke
that is pressed on a keyboard is
actually an event and as we have
discussed before that an event is
anything that is happening inside our
game window any kind of input control so
for example if we move our mouse we
click somewhere we close this window so
this is a quit event and similarly
whenever we press any key stroke on our
keyboard it is a key stroke event so for
example every event gets locked inside
this PI game dot event dot ket and we
loop through all the events that are
being stored inside it and then after
every iteration so for example let's say
in the first iteration of this while
loop a keystroke is not being placed but
on the 10th iteration a keystroke is
being pressed then it will get stored
inside the spy game not even dot get and
we'll be able to look through that and
check whether a keystroke has been
pressed or not so inside this I'm just
gonna write an if condition which says
actually before that let me just add a
comment so that you guys understand what
we are doing I'm gonna write if
keystroke
keystroke is pressed check whether is
right or left so this is basically what
we will be doing Thank You stroke of
keystroke oh oh I'm gonna mess up my
spelling son all right keystroke can't
get this feeling right it's all right
so anyways how do you check with your
keystroke is being pressed or not my
game makes it really really easy it's
kind of an event which is I game dot key
dump
so this basically check if any keystroke
it doesn't have to be left or the right
it can be alphabet a even backspace or
space it basically checks if any
keystroke is being pressed so first we
are going to do that we are going to
write if event dot type which we did
inside this if condition so we have to
go actually inside this for loop so if
we will just press this button over here
let's press this so now we are inside
this event for loop and now we are
looping through all the events that are
there and if the event dot type is
equals equals to PI game dot key key
down then this means that a keystroke
has been pressed on a computer and now
we have to check whether the keystroke
that was pressed is left all right
so this is also pretty easy we just
again type event dot this time we type
in dot key because you want to find out
the key that is being pressed and we
just type in Pi game dot key left okay
left and this will just check whether
the key that is being pressed is the
left arrow or not if that is the left
eye releases for right now printer left
arrow is pressed
and after that I'm gonna write again I'm
just gonna copy and paste this over here
like this and over here I'm just gonna
write write and instead of key
underscore I'm gonna add the right all
right so basically what this does is it
checks whether any keystroke is pressed
and then it checks whether the keystroke
that is being pressed is left or right
and after that we are going to check
when the keystroke is being released so
after pressing down on the left arrow
key when we remove our finger from that
left arrow key that is known as a
removal of the keystroke or the key up
so key down is pressing that key or
pressing any button on the keyboard and
key up is basically releasing that press
so we are going to check for that over
here if event dot type is equals to
equals to PI game dot key up so
hopefully we'll be able to find that key
up over here and then over here we are
just gonna check if it was the left key
or the right arrow key and then we are
going to print something so that is
pretty simple we can just copy this from
here let's copy this paste this and we
are gonna give a condition that if the
left or the right arrow key was pressed
so you can just copy this from here and
put this colon mark and then over here
we are just gonna write keystroke has
been released just so you guys know what
is going on and I want you to write this
code down and then actually try it out
yourself so that you guys know what's
happening behind the scenes so now we
can just press play and over here is
gonna do nothing but on a print screen
over here we are printing all of these
things so let's press the left arrow key
and see if something happens so we have
to first eat our window over here and
then we can press the left arrow key and
you can see that the left arrow is
pressed and when I remove my finger it
says keystroke has been released now
what if I keep pressing on the left
arrow key if I keep pressing it will
just say left arrow is pressed and the
keystroke has been released and
similarly if I press the right arrow key
it says right arrow is pressed but if I
press any other key it prints nothing
so let's actually print a statement over
here to let's say a keystroke is pressed
so that we know when any other key is
pressed it also runs so over here we can
just press the left arrow key again as
you can see a keystroke is press left
arrow keys pressed and keystroke has
been released but if you press something
else let's say enter it just says a
keystroke is pressed and not the left
and the right arrow key and that means
that our keyboard strokes are working so
now we can just minimize it and we are
going to create a new variable over here
and this will signify the change that we
want in X so if you want the X to move
in right hand direction we need to add
value to this 370 existing value and if
we wanted to move on the left hand side
direction we need to decrease value from
it so I'm going to just call it over
here create a new variable and call it
player X underscore change equals 2 and
right now I'm going to give it a value
of 0 and inside our if conditions when
the left key is pressed I want it to
increase by 0.1 and when sorry decrease
by 0.1 and we don't change the 0.1
number it basically signifies the speed
with which you want the object to move
and in this case is spaceship how
quickly you want the spaceship to move
and we are going to change it later and
even in this video we will see how it
goes if it moves too slowly or too fast
but anyways right now we are going to
decrease the value when the left key is
placed and increase the value when the
right key is pressed so what kind of
change do we want in our X when we want
the left arrow key is pressed so we're
gonna just right over here player X and
let's go change and we want to decrease
the value by 0.1 let's say and when the
right arrow key is pressed we want to
increase this change by 0.1 so let's
remove this minus value from over here
and when the key is released we want the
spaceship to stop moving and that is why
we want the change to be zero when our
keystroke is released
so over here we are just gonna paste
this over here so this is looking pretty
good let's actually move this comment
from here and then we can just add this
player exchange to our existing player X
x-coordinates so I'm just gonna write
clear X plus equals two and then player
exchange so doesn't matter whether we
are adding over here because we have can
atom value of minus 0.1 and over here we
are giving it a positive value so
whenever something is added and the
value is negative so I'm just gonna give
you an example alright so that you guys
can understand this arithmetic properly
you might be thinking that why are we
adding over here because we want to
subtract this zero point one right so
let's say our current value is 370 let's
say I actually take a smaller value
let's take out clear x-coordinate is 5
and then when we do plus equal to so
this basically means equals to 5 plus
and then the value that is player X and
the score change so night now this value
is minus 0.1 if the key left is
activated so this value will be actually
minus 0.1 so after this arithmetic is
processed this will turn actually into
so let me just add arrow key this will
actually turn into five equals to five
minus zero point one and similarly if we
add then the addition is pretty pretty
like obvious so we can just add zero
point one and this will remain the same
just zero point 1 and the value will be
five point one so this is how this
operate over here works so we don't need
to worry about whether we are
subtracting or adding if we have added
our arithmetic operator over here in
this case it's minus so this should be
working let's run our main dot Piatt
file and see if it is working
so let's activate it and over here when
you press a left arrow key our ship is
moving and when we press the right arrow
key our ship is moving and we when we
release the keystroke it is still moving
why is that the case so let's go over
here and see all right so here the place
X underscore change is zero point one so
we have to change it to value zero
because we don't want it to move you can
actually change it to zero point one to
see how it works how the spaceship is
stopping so let's try it again now then
you move on the right hand direction and
we release the keystroke the ship
actually stops so this is looking pretty
good but astley
this the speed is a little bit slow so
I'm going to increase the value to zero
point three and now if we run it our
speed should be sufficiently well so
yeah this is looking pretty good and
future will change is zero point three
to a higher value when we use the clock
concept but we are not using it right
now so this is looking pretty good
a spaceship is moving perfectly and just
to recap what we did in this video was
first we checked whether any keystroke
has impressed on the keyboard and then
if the left keystroke is pressed then we
increase or decrease the value of player
exchange by 0.3 and if our right key is
played then we increase the value by 0.3
and when our keystroke has been released
you make sure that the player
x-coordinate stops changing and that is
why we have given it the value of zero
to make sure that the spaceship stops
and doesn't go on and then we just use
this arithmetic thing over here which
increases the value of player X or
decreases the value of player X
depending upon the value of this player
X underscore change so this guy's this
is looking pretty good in the next video
if you have any queries please ask them
in questions so this is pretty much it
for this video in the next video we are
gonna give our spaceship and enemy
because right now is the space is
looking very lonely for a spaceship it's
just going in the space and it's not
finding any planets or any enemies so
it's thinking about its existence and
the meaning of life so what's happening
with me so we are gonna give it a
meaning in the next video so I'll see
you over there
and the last video we learned how to
move our spaceship using our keyboard in
the left and the right hand side
direction and this video is about to
give it some enemies but then I realized
our spaceship is just moving out of the
screen when you go to the left and when
we go to the right so why is this
happening so when it goes to the right
this right border of the spaceship of
our game window it actually reaches the
800 width that we have set and when it
goes beyond this 800 it goes to maybe
810 and 805 pixels so there's no
restriction right now to the spaceship
movement in the left and the right hand
side direction and similarly when it
moves to left hand side it goes in a
little bit lesser than 0 angles goes
into - territory because this
x-coordinate is an integer this that's
why it can go to negatives and even it
can go to minus 450 or something
so what what should we do so what we are
going to do is that when it reaches the
zero coordinate then we are going to any
time it goes into negative stuff we are
going to make sure that it stays at zero
by using an if condition so we are going
to basically tell our spaceship that hey
if your x-coordinate reaches zero or
less than zero make sure it turns back
to zero and similarly on the right hand
side we are going to tell our spaceship
if your x-coordinate reaches this 800
x-coordinate back then I don't want you
to go beyond it and change your
x-coordinate to 800 again so every time
it goes beyond 800 it's gonna just
delete itself and go back to 800 by it's
gonna happen so quickly that the eyes
won't see it and it will look like that
the spaceship can't go beyond 800 so
let's do that that's right an F
condition just beyond this arithmetic
operator we have over here and as I said
we are just gonna right player X if this
player X becomes less than 0 that is the
x-coordinate becomes less than 0 then we
are going to change the value of player
X to 0 and similarly if our let's write
LF
if player X becomes greater than or
equal to 7 36 pixels so why are we
taking this 730 pick 36 pixels instead
of 800 pixels so because our pixel we
have to take into consideration the size
of our spaceship so if you remember the
PNG size of the spaceship is 64 by 64
pixels so the width of this spaceship is
64 pixels that is why we are subtracting
64 from 800 and that means 736 pixels so
if we chose any other number for example
800 then it will stop at this point and
not before that but we want to stop over
here and not allow any part of spaceship
to appear beyond the game window so
that's why we are choosing this 736
pixel number we just subtracted 64 from
800 and over here we are just gonna
change the value of 4 whenever it goes
beyond 736 we wanted to again go cell to
2 back to 736 x-coordinate and this will
mean that it will look that it cannot go
beyond but it is actually but it's just
deleting that spaceship and creating a
new one at 736 x-coordinate pixel so
let's check this out and hopefully it
works
well let's reload it and let's see if it
works or not so as you can see when i
press the right arrow key it doesn't
move beyond this and feel free to try it
yourself and change the x coordinates
just experiment with it a little bit so
the last video was pretty long and this
video is pretty short so that's good so
in the next video we are finally going
to create an enemy for a spaceship so
I'll see you over there
and the last video we learned how to
create boundaries for a spaceship so
that it doesn't go out of bounds
in this video we are going to give it
our first enemy so I've already
downloaded an enemy image which looks
like a happy space invader it's not
gonna be so happy when we shoot it with
a spaceship but anyways let's get the
cycle from flat I can calm just like we
always have and search for space
invaders and I'm gonna go with this red
space and video you can select whatever
you want and download the 64 by 64
picture as usual obviously in the PNG
format so now we can go back to our code
and just like we did with our player we
can add this enemy dot PNG inside our
code so let's do that let's just copy
this whole code and just add it below
the player change it to enemy so we're
gonna change everything to enemy so we
just have to rename everything let's
call it enemy and then I'm just gonna
copy and paste this in the remaining
areas so let's just copy and paste
everything and instead of the player dot
PNG we are gonna call it the enemy dot
PNG and make sure you rename the PNG
file otherwise you try it if you read
enemy dot PNG is not going to work but
anyway so we need to also create this
function again so let's just copy and
paste this too so we're not a basis over
here instead of player we are gonna call
it the enemy and everything else should
remain the same that's formatted
properly another thing is in PyCharm if
you want to format everything properly
if you have written code that's not
formatted and doesn't look good what you
can do is you can just press ctrl Alt +
L and it will format everything properly
inside your code so it's just ctrl L as
you can see it says imports optimized it
will just make your code look good so
again the command is ctrl + Alt + L on
your keyboard
so anyways now that we have added the
function of the enemy let's just go down
below and add the enemy over here so
that we can call the function while our
one loop is running so let's add the
enemy over here and instead of the
let's just call it enemy and instead of
the player X we are gonna call enemy X
and instead of player Y you're gonna
give it a value of any Y so right now
you can see that the coordinates are the
same as all the spaceships so this
should overlap our spaceship so let's
see if it's overlapping or not so right
now it's not overlapping let's let's
actually check out where is that
happening
so this is because inside that enemy
function we have not renamed this to
enemy dot AMJ so let's do that let's
rename it enemy dot image and then just
reload it and this should work properly
so now you can see that the enemy is in
top of the spaceship but this is not we
want we want the enemy to be like
somewhere on the top so maybe in the
middle but on the top so we can let the
enemy X remain the same but I'm going to
change the MU by to something else
let's give it a value of 50 I've already
tried it out and 50 looks pretty good so
let's see how it looks alright so our
spaceship is moving and we have an enemy
but the problem with this enemy is that
it's not moving it's very boring so
we're gonna fix that in the next video
but for right now what I want is that
this enemy should appear in the random
places so whenever we kill an enemy it
is going to appear again or in the game
terms is going to respawn again so I
wanted to respawn in different places
maybe on different x axis so maybe like
maybe over here over here after its
killed and maybe in Y should also appear
in different places so maybe next time
over here next time over here so you
wanted to appear in different places so
every time it reloads basically we want
it to appear in different places and
even at the starting of the game it
should not be constant it should be
totally random so what we are going to
do is we are gonna make this anyway X
and enemy Y actually random so we have
to first write down the line that imp
actually helps us randomize values so we
are gonna import a package known as a
random and this is pretty easy to do so
let me just minimize this over here and
then scroll down and over here we are
just going to write instead of 370 we
are just gonna write random dot R and
int so this is a method inside the
package to choose a random integer
between two values and then we have to
give it the value that we want so we
want a starting value and an end value
so in our game we want it to appear
anywhere between 0 and 800 so we are
going to give it the starting value of 0
and the end value of 800 and similarly
with why we wanted to give a value
between maybe 50 and 150 so let's change
this to 50 the 50 should be the starting
point so the minimum height should be 50
and then it can go down over here let's
say 150 it's approximately 150 so I'm
going to give it a value of 150 all
right guys so this is looking pretty
good let's just run it again and see if
it works so let's run me all right so
this is working it respawned over here
let's reload it to see if it responds
somewhere else
let's just reload it and see where this
time it appears this time it appears
over here let's try the third time third
time is a charm and it always works so
this time it appears over here so our
program is looking pretty good we have
created an enemy and it is respawning in
different places so this is just looking
pretty good in the next video we are
going to make sure that our enemy moves
so right now our enemy is stationary
it's not moving from the left or the
right and it's not going down so we are
going to make sure that we rectify that
in the next video is going to be really
exciting so I'll see you over there
so in the last video we created our
enemy and made sure we applied
randomization to our enemy so that when
it gets destroyed and created again it
should appear in random places so as you
can see when we reload our program is
going to respawn in a different place so
in this video we are going to make sure
that our enemy is moving so imagine that
there are multiple enemies right now
there is just when one enemy and we
haven't created multiple enemy so there
is not any problem but imagine there are
multiple enemies and they are moving
from left to right and then also when
they hit the boundary they come a little
bit down so that's what we are going to
be focusing on today we are not going to
be creating multiple enemies but we are
going to be focusing on the movement of
this one single enemy and then we can
apply it to multiple enemies but let's
for right now just focus on one enemy so
what exactly do we want from this enemy
what kind of movement do we want so what
we wanted to do is move from right to
left in X direction so for example this
enemy will move in the right-hand side
and when it hits the boundary that is
about 736 or 800 pixels it should change
its direction and move towards the
left-hand side and when it reaches the
left-hand side then again when it hits
that zero coordinate x coordinate then
it should again change this direction
and move towards the right hand side so
this is the movement in the X direction
now there is also a movement in the Y
direction so whenever it hits a boundary
whether it can be right boundary or the
left boundary then it should come a
little bit down so that imagine there
are multiple enemies and we are trying
to shoot all of those enemies down so
how will the game get over so whenever
these enemies hit the boundaries and
come down at one point of time they are
going to hit the spaceship as they are
coming down and then we will make it
game over like in the classic space
invaders so we need to execute the X
movement as well as we need to execute
the Y movement now this orbit is going
to be very easy because you already know
how to move the spaceship and we are
going to do the same thing that we did
in the player so first of all we will
just scroll up let's minimize this over
here so we are going to slow up and
because our enemy is going to have
the exchange as well as the five
movement so I'm just gonna copy this
over here and also make sure that we add
our by movement now enemy exchange over
here we are gonna give it the value of
0.3 maybe in future we'll speed it up
because a spaceship is also at the speed
of exchange of 0.3 maybe we'll change it
up on future but right now I'm just
gonna give it a value of 0.3 now I'm not
giving it a value so for example in
player we haven't we have just given it
a value of 0 over here and below over
here we have changed its direction by
typing in negative and positive yeah not
gonna do this with our enemy vs gonna
provide the value of 0.3 over here now
if you scroll down you're just gonna do
the same thing that we did with our
player so for example over here we made
sure that if it hit the boundary so this
is the algorithm basically you can call
it the algorithm but it is pretty simple
so whenever it hits the zero coordinate
we change its value to zero and whenever
it gets greater than cents 36 we make
sure that it coordinates get to 736
again and this prevents the spaceship
from going out of bounds so this is a
kind of way of checking the boundary so
we can do the same thing with our enemy
so let me just copy and paste this over
here and instead of every way player
we're just gonna call it enemy so he
should be in small so over here also let
me just copy actually and me and paste
it everywhere this is gonna make sure
that we save up some time not a lot of
time but so let's face this enemy over
here yeah I wish there was a quicker way
to do it but it's not so anyways now I'm
just going to add a comment over here so
that you guys can understand what we are
talking about over here so checking for
boundaries of spaceship so it doesn't go
out of bounds
no he always gonna write maybe enemy
movement anyway movement and this looks
pretty good now instead of restricting
us what we want is whenever a boundary
is hit we want it to go someplace so for
example when it hits that left boundary
we want to increase the value of x so
that it starts going in the right hand
side direction and similarly when it
hits this right-hand side boundary then
we want to decrease the value of x and
this will keep on happening because it's
inside our while loop so now we are
going to use the same arithmetic
operation that we used with our players
so if we scroll up a little bit you can
see when we wanted to change directions
we give when we wanted to move towards
the left we gave it a value of minus and
when you want it to move towards the
right we gave it a positive value of 0.3
and then we just added because of this
arithmetic property so we are going to
do the same thing over here so instead
of enemy x equals to zero what we are
going to do is we are going to write and
me exchange equals to zero point three
and so so that basically when it hits
this left hand side that is the zero
coordinate it can start going to a some
other direction that is it should start
increasing the x value and similarly we
want when we want it to go left hand
side we are going to change it to a
minus value so we are gonna give it a
value of minus and this should be enough
guy so and actually if I scroll up you
can see that I put the value of enemy X
and the score change equal to zero point
three we can leave it to zero or we can
give it to zero point three it doesn't
really matter so let's run it and see if
it works let me just close down the
previous implementation so that we don't
get confused and I'm just gonna run it
again run main and hopefully the enemy
will start moving
so you can see that the enemy is moving
from left hand side to right hand side
and actually this looks pretty awesome
so now you can see that it's not moving
in the y direction as it's just moving
in the X direction so what we want is
that when it hits the right boundary you
should move downwards or even if it hits
the left boundary it should move a
little bit downwards so what I'm going
to do is I'm
go over here and I'm gonna add and he
white change equals to 40 so that we can
move it down by 40 pixels so white when
do we want it to move down we wanted to
move down when it hits the boundary that
is the real coordinate or the 736
coordinate so we can just increase the
value of y over here and that should be
enough so I'm just gonna write in me y
plus equals 2 and then we want the enemy
Y change
just let it let's just paste over here
and then we can do the same thing over
here it's not it is that let's just add
it over here so now let's just reload it
and see how it looks now you can see
when it hits the boundary it actually
goes a little bit down so you can
imagine multiple enemies when they are
hitting the boundary they are going down
so it's gonna be a little bit difficult
for a spaceship to eliminate all of them
but it's going to try its best and when
this enemy reaches the spaceship we are
gonna give it our game over and
depending upon how many enemies we can
hit with a bullet which will be creating
mostly in the next video or in the
coming up videos depending upon how many
enemies he can eliminate with that
bullet the score is going to be
according to that so you can't kind of
get the idea of the game with this video
as to how the game was going to look so
today we are going to be learning about
adding background image to our PI game
so right now if we open up our space and
wait again you will be able to see that
we haven't in me we have in spaceship
but it's happening in the black
background it doesn't look that good we
need to add some kind of a space
background to make it very cool so what
I'm going to do is I'm already
downloading an image of a background
that is background or PNG and it
somewhat looks like this so how did I
get this image so what I did was I went
to this website called free pick Calm
Pik and then free free pick calm and I
searched for this text which says
colorful spaceship background obviously
feel free to get an image from wherever
you want but make sure you get an image
that's 800 into 600 pixels why is that
sighs because our game window is of that
size as you can see we have made a game
window of this area so what I did was I
went over there and you can choose any
of these images but the image that I
chose was this one and then I used
illustrator so free because the website
was gonna give you a lot of Illustrator
Photoshop stuff and you have to edit it
out to make it your own so I removed all
of the weird stuff that we didn't want
for example this rocket this text and
stuff so I removed all of that stuff and
if you know illustrator feel free to
make a new match on your own so what I'm
going to do for you guys if you're not
able to get this image on your own is
that I'm going to attach it to the
description or attach it somewhere so
that you guys can get this image just
look at this videos text so what I'm
going to do is after we download this
background image to our project folder
make sure you do that then we're just
gonna add it to our windows so over here
how do we add images to our program is
just by PI game dot image node so I'm
going to do that so I'm gonna add a
comment let's say and we are gonna write
just background let's just try it
background and then I'm going to create
a variable called background I'm gonna
do the same thing that we did with the
rest so I'm just going to copy and paste
it over here and instead of UFO I'm
gonna write that crowd so obviously my
image is
800 into 600 pixels so make sure it is
of that size so now that we have added
it if we run it right now it's not going
to appear because it just appears for a
second and then it disappears we want it
to persist so how do we make it pulse s
is by adding it to our while loop so we
need to make sure that we go to our
while loop over here and we are going to
add it just below the screen dot fill
because if we don't then this black
color is going to be on top of our
background image which we don't want so
what I'm going to do is I'm just gonna
add another comment over here which is
gonna say a background image and we
forgot the B so let's at B and then over
here we are just going to do the screen
just because things we do when we want
to add an image which is screen dot
split so basically draw the background
image and then we need the variable of
the image so that is background and then
we need to add the coordinates of our
image so we just wanted to appear from
the top left corner so we are gonna add
0 comma 0 and that should be pretty good
so let's run our main dot buy a program
let's run me and you will be able to see
that our background is there but the
problem with the background and anything
and a spaceship is now that they are
moving very very slowly and what is this
so if your pause this video and figure
it on your own that would be pretty cool
but I'm just gonna explain it over here
so our background or PNG is actually two
twenty six pixels sorry 226 KB so it's a
little bit heavy but what happens is
when this while loop is running every
iteration of this while loop previously
used to happen relatively fast
but now because it has to load this
heavy background image the iteration of
this while loop every iteration is a
little bit more slow so that is whenever
we are increasing the value over here so
for example we are increasing the value
of player it is too small so whenever
this while loop is going is just
increase in the value but zero point
three which is very slow and that's why
it's not able to move around a lot so
what we are going to do is we are going
to just increase the value to five of
our players and I'm gonna change the
value of our enemies so let's see where
as enemy so here on me I am gonna give
it a value of let's say 4 I just want
these enemies to be a little bit
a spaceship because when they are going
to be multiple enemies then we don't
want them to appear like really really
fast so let's reload it now and see if
it works so it's still slow why is this
happening a spaceship has increased its
movement but the enemy is still slow so
let's see if somewhere our old values
are still persisting so enemy we have
changed the x value over here so let's
go up and see where we have not changed
the value so over here are the enemy
exchanges still 0.3 so we have to change
it over here too let's make it four and
now we can reload it and you will be
able to see that the enemy is moving at
a good speed so now we have the
background image we have our spaceship
and we have our enemy the only thing
missing is the bullets because we don't
have the bullets right now to kill this
enemy so the next video we are going to
make our bullets or get started with
making our butt so I'll see you over
there
is in this video we are going to learn
how to shoot our bullet inside our game
window so as you can see I am shooting a
bullet and the enemy so right now the
bullet is not hurting the enemy because
we haven't implemented the collision yet
but more than that in the future videos
in this video we are just going to learn
how to shoot a bullet so let's get
started but before we get started with
the code I just wanted to explain a
couple of things and the first thing I
wanted to explain is what's the starting
position of the bullet so when we are in
the middle of the window that has at 370
pixel x-coordinate approximately it's
shooting from the top of a spaceship but
if we move left it's still shooting at
the x-coordinate of our spaceship it
doesn't matter where our spaceship is
the x-coordinate of the bullet is going
to be always equal to that of our
spaceship just the starting positions
for example if we shoot the bullet right
now even if we move a spaceship the
bullet is not moving with our spaceship
this is the starting position of the
bullet is equal to that of our spaceship
so that is the first thing and the
second thing is that as we shoot the
bullet the bullets of Y value is
decreasing so because at the bottom the
value is 600 y-coordinate and as we go
up the value of pi' decreases and at the
top it's actually zero so at the top the
y-coordinate of Y of our bullet is going
to be zero so we have to decrease the
value from about 480 pixels so because
this 480 coordinate y-coordinate and we
are going to decrease it as we go
towards the top so right now you can see
that is disappearing at the top so the
third thing I want to talk about before
we go into code because so important to
understand is the state of the bullet so
right now when you can't see the bullet
its state is at ready but when you can
see the bullet State is going to be at
fire so right now it's not appearing on
the screen that is that means that we
are readying the bullet for fire
and when it shoots you can see the
bullet and that means the bullet has
been fired so let's not do between that
filing period anything so this is what
it means obviously you are going to
understand it more as we write down the
code so let's get started with that so
the first thing we need to do is act an
image of a bullet inside our project
folder and I have already added it as
you can see on the left hand side
bullet dot PNG and it kind of looks like
this so how can you get this image so
you can just go to flat icon comm like
we have done previously and search for
this bullet and you can just download
this bullet from here and obviously you
can choose any bullet that you want and
even through Google or something but
make you when you download this image
it's 32 by 32 pixels so this bullet is
not the same as I'm using but if you
want you can just go to the sixth or
seven page of this flat icon calm and
you will find the same image but feel
free to use this image it doesn't make a
lot of difference so now when you have
downloaded this bullet dot PNG make sure
it's 32 by 32 pixels let me just close
this Photoshop this is the back room you
made the last video so after adding the
bullet dot PNG we are going to add it
into our PI code so over here just below
the enemy we are just gonna copy this
enemy because we don't want to create
everything again and instead of anyway
where is is gonna write bullet and we
are going to replace everything of our
enemy with our bullets so let's call it
bullet and then I'm just gonna copy and
paste everything so for the Dex bullet
why and just paste it put it exchange
and some of these values we are not
gonna use so for example bullet is not
going to move in the x-direction so
using the X X underscore change is
useless but still we are gonna just keep
it over here just for this sake of
conformity but anyways in this bullet X
and bullet Y we are going to give the
value of zero bullet X because we are
going to be changing the value inside
our while loop but bullet Y is going to
be at 480 pixels why is that because our
spaceship as you can see as player Y is
at 480 pixels so at that level the
bullet is always going to be shortened
so if I run this mean program over here
you can see that a spaceship is over
here and what's happening to hot enemy
let's reload it let's see if we have
done something to have any me know so as
you can see when we move our spaceship
it's not moving in the Y direction so we
need to shoot our bullet from its top of
its nose which is at 480 pixels of y
coordinate that's why we have good end
this 480 over here
and then we are going to add another
variable is going to be bullet state so
this is the state I was talking about a
few seconds ago so we are gonna add a
variable bullet state and we are going
to give it a value of ready so let me
just add a comment actually over here so
that you guys remember what this ready
state is what is fire state so ready
state basically means you can't see the
bullet on the screen and fire the bullet
is currently moving alright so this is
the state we are going to be using to
basically differentiate between whether
the bullet is in motion or it's in a
state of constant and it's not being
fired right now and it's going to help
us decide the movement dynamics of our
bullet so now we have created another
bullet state equals two ready and now we
are going to create a function known as
fire bullet that is going to be called
whenever we press our space but so in
our game whenever if we press our
spacebar of a bullet is being fired so
that is what we want and pressing the
spacebar but it gets fired so and what
happens when I press spacebar we want
this function of fire underscore bullet
to be called and we are going to do the
same thing over here we are going to
call the x and y variables and just
below that we are going to access this
bullet underscore state where bill
equals two ready inside our function now
how do you do that we need to create
this bullet underscore state function as
global so that it can be accessed inside
this function so I'm just going to write
global and then pull it state and now we
can access the value of this British
state from inside this function so after
this after we press space the bullet is
actually being fired so now you can see
it on that screen so we need to change
the state of the bullet equals to five
so now it's not ready it's actually
being fired currency in motion after
that we just need to make sure that it
appears on the screen so I'm going to
write screaming dot plate we need to
draw the bullet on the screen and then
I'm going to write the name of our
bullet image bullet image
and then we are going to write the
coordinates of where do we want it to
appear so we just wanted to appear on X
comma Y the values that you are getting
from the function now we want this
values to be at X plus 16 and y plus 10
why is that so let me just format
everything properly and you can press
ctrl alt + L if you are using pie Chomp
to make sure that it looks good so why
are we doing this x + 16 y + 10 this is
to make sure that the bullet appears on
the center of a spaceship if you don't
do plus 16 it is going to appear on the
left hand side of the spaceship a little
bit I have already tried it out so
that's why I know section is the correct
value and this y is just make sure that
it appears a little bit above spaceship
just to give it an illusion of the
bullet being fired from the top of the
nose and not from the center of the
spaceship and now before we go into the
while loop I just want to change the
value of change in Y because I'm put it
is moving in the Y direction and this is
the value that we gave to the enemy we
don't want the bullet to move this fast
we wanted to move at the speed of 10 so
let's close this window now and let's
just go below and what we want over here
is that if an arrow key of space not an
arrow key if a keystroke of space on our
keyboard is pressed then we want to call
that fire under scope will it function
so let's create that over here so now we
can just copy and paste this line and
then at the end we can just add the
value of space so K underscore space and
this is going to make sure that we can
capture the value of space and what we
want when you press the space we want
the fire bullet function to be called
and now what are the values inside this
so right now we are just gonna give it a
value of clear X but you'll understand
why this is strong but this is just a
like a logic error so I'm not gonna
worry about it too much but I'm gonna
tell you why it's strong and we are
going to fix this in this video so let's
try it if event dot keep I game dot K
underscore space fire underscore bullet
player X comma Y so let's run this right
now and see how it looks obviously it's
not complete not even close to complete
but we are going to
it looks so I know you can see but it is
not there but when we press the space
nothing is happening and the enemy is
appearing for some reason over here a
few speak if you seen yet near the
spaceship the enemy is appearing because
we haven't changed the name of our image
so let's go to the other bullet and over
here instead of enemy we are gonna call
it bullet I know when I was recording
this and you I was just writing the this
line you might guys must have screamed
that hey this should be bullet dot PNG
not enemy not PNG but no race we have
changed our value and now if we come
back you can see that you can't really
see the bullet over here but it's
actually appearing but it's appearing so
fast that you can't see it so actually
let me just change it to enemy again so
that you guys can at least see it it's
happening behind the screen so let me
run this and when we press space you can
see that the enemy is appearing at near
the spaceship you can see this this is
happening so this is how the bullet is
also appearing but right now you just
can't see it so let's change this back
to bullet dot PNG so we need to do a
couple of things so why is it appearing
and disappearing so quickly what we need
to do is we need to make sure that it
persists in the background and when we
need anything to persist in pygame we
added to our infinite while loop so
right now this code is only being called
when we press the spacebar we want this
bullet to appear and then not disappear
a little acquittee so we are gonna add
another comment over here and we're
going to call this bullet movement
bullet movement and over here we are
gonna just change the values and first
check the maybe the state of our bullet
so right now a state is when you press
the spacebar then the state changes to
fire but at default the state always
remains at ready so as you can see that
the bullet in the score state is equal
to ready and when we press the spacebar
the fire underscore bullet function is
called and inside the function the state
changes to fire so outside over here we
can write and condition
if well the state is fire then we can
actually move the bullet in front of the
spaceship and make sure it decreases in
Y so we're going to add some values and
we're going to call this fire bullet
function again over here and we are
going to get rid of value of player X
and we are going to give it the value of
y and just below this we are going to
decrease the value of our bullet just
like we discussed at the starting of the
video minus plus minus equal minus equal
to bullet Y change which is currently 10
so let's run this program now and see if
it works
so this is our spaceship and what's
happening to our enemy Y is going crazy
we just reload this what's up with this
enemy all right so now you can see that
the bullet is moving but this there is
there are two problems in this first V
and only Phi of one bullet so you can
see after we have fired one bullet we
can't fire another bullet so that's one
problem and the second problem is that
when you fire the bullet when we move
our spaceship the bullet is moving with
our spaceship just to give you guys
another view when you press space the
bullet is going and when we move the
spaceship the bullet is actually moving
with the spaceship so we will be solving
both of these problems in the next video
for right now I'm just going to give you
a recap so that you guys can understand
properly what is going on so let's go
from the moment we press the spacebar so
when you press the spacebar this event
of spacebar is triggered and this fire
bullet function is called and over here
we send two values that is the current
position of player X and a bullet Y
value the bullet Y value is 480 y
coordinate and the player X is the
movement where the spaceship is the x
coordinate of the spaceship and that is
partly the reason why the bullet is
moving in the direction of the spaceship
I do I'm going to tackle that in the
next video so for right now we are
calling this fire bullet function
whenever the space key is pressed and
you are transferring the value of plane
X and bullet by two are fired underscore
pilot function now this fire bullet
function is to changing the state of our
bullet state underscore to fire so that
when we execute this while loop all this
code can be executed
so we are finally firing the bullet and
to fire the ability we first need to
show it on the screen so we are blading
it out or drawing it on the screen and
we have changed the value of 16 and wise
so just to show you guys why we have
change the values let me actually remove
the X and y values so that you guys can
see the difference so I'm just gonna
turn play and I'm gonna shoot a bullet
as you can see this bullet is being shot
a little bit from the left hand side and
we want it to be shot from the middle of
the screen that is why I did that so in
the middle of the spaceship not in the
from the middle of the screen to be
exact but anyways after we did this fire
underscore buret function has been
called the bridge state has been
returned to fire and then we go to this
infinite while loop which is running but
it wasn't running because before running
the spacebar or before pressing the
space but the bullet State was ready so
all of this code was not getting
executed but after pressing the spacebar
the bullet State has been changed to
fire so now we can plate this out on the
screen by calling this fire under
component function and we can start
actually changing the location of the
bullet by moving it in the upward
direction by reducing the value of y so
guys this was the logic of our bullets
in the next video we are going to tackle
the two problems that we have discussed
in this video so I'll see you over there
the last video we learned how to shoot a
bullet but there are a couple of
problems with our program right now we
can shoot only one bullet at a time and
that said that's it for the whole game
so that's a pretty big problem and the
second problem is that the bullet is
always following our spaceship doesn't
matter where it go bullet will follow it
and we wanted to have an individual path
so for example we wanted to have we want
the bullet to have the starting point of
a spaceship the x-coordinate of a
spaceship but when we move the spaceship
the bullet should continue on its
original x-coordinate and not of our
current spaceships so these are two
problems we are going to solve so let's
solve the first problem first of having
multiple bullets so for that what we are
going to do is we are going to add an if
condition so right now if you watch over
here when the bullet goes up it goes to
the zero coordinate and then you're not
doing anything to a bullet so it just
keeps on going into negative values and
we are not removing the bullet from our
screen so what we need to do is as soon
as this crosses the zero coordinate we
need to make sure that it resets to the
value of 480 so as soon as soon as it
goes above zero coordinate two things
are going to happen first is going to
reset to 480 pixels of Y and the second
thing is because you can't see it on the
screen anymore because it has gone
beyond zero y-coordinate we are going to
change the state of a bullet to ready
again so that we can fire it the next
time so let me just add an if condition
which beneath this bullet movement which
says if bullet Y is less than equals to
zero because above zero is going to be
negative values and over here we are
going to do thing two things first is we
are going to reset the state of the
bullet that is the bullet Y should be
reset it to 480 again and the second
thing is we need to change of the bullet
state so below state is going to be
ready again and let's make sure that we
don't misspell anything and we are going
to format just properly press ENTER and
now let's reload it and you will be able
to see that our bullet is multiple so
right now you can see we are short one
bullet then we can shoot another bullet
and it keeps on happening and now that
we have fixed the first problem let's
focus on the other problem and that
that the bullet is following our
spaceship so why is this happening this
is happening because in our code we are
still using the player x value so if we
go to our space condition so after
pressing space we are using the player x
value and even in our violin if
condition code of over here we are still
using the player x value so it's alright
that we want the starting position of
our bullet do we add the spaceship let
me just remove this recording thing so
at the starting position we want the
bullet to be at the x coordinate of a
spaceship so when you press space the
bullet starts from the spaceship and not
from somewhere else so for example over
here we want the x coordinate of a
bullet to be that of the x coordinate of
our spaceship but when we move after
firing the spaceship the x coordinate
shouldn't follow the spaceship so that
is the problem that we are having so how
do we solve that
so instead of using the bullet the space
player x value everywhere we just just
use when we press the spacebar one value
of the x coordinate just should be just
saved so we are going to do that we are
just going to write bullet X we haven't
used this variable yet and we are going
to save the value of clear x over here
and then insert it off player x we are
going to send the value of bullet x to
our fire bullet function and we are
going to do the same thing over here in
our if condition so instead of player X
you are going to use the value of bullet
X and that should solve the problem so
let's run our main program again and see
if it works so this is a spaceship and
now if we move our spaceship the bullet
is not following our spaceship so we add
what we have done is when the spacebar
is pressed then we have saved the
current spaceship x coordinate inside
our bullet X variable and then we are
using that everywhere instead of just
using player X so now that we have fixed
that there is one more problem to fix
which I've just realized so the problem
is that after pressing if we press the
bull spacebar again so for example we
have press the spacebar the bullet is
going and then if we press the spacebar
multiple times
is going to change just keep on moving
according to our spaceship so multiple
space bar changes its x-coordinate and
why is that happening so while the
bullet isn't moving condition it's in
fire condition even in that condition we
can press our spacebar so we have to
make sure that we can only press the
spacebar when it's in ready condition so
we are going to add a if condition over
here which says if bullet state is ready
let's add double quotes for the string
if the bullet state is steady only then
we can fire another bullet otherwise we
can't fire another bullet so after our
bullet goes above this zero coordinate
or our bullet is in ready state only
then we can fire another bullet so now
if you press space all the errors have
been fixed except this first one I don't
know what happens to us sometimes all
right so let's shoot and you can see
that after hit has crossed the zero
coordinate and it resets to 480
y-coordinate again only then we can
shoot another bullet so this is looking
pretty good guys
we have finally completed the bullet
module this was a pretty long module
because there were a lot of
complications in it and a lot of things
to understand so let me just recap so
that you guys can understand everything
properly so if anybody has understood
everything perfectly you guys can just
stop this video so what happens when you
press the spacebar when you press the
spacebar first it checks whether a
bullet is already on the screen or not
if it's not on the screen then it makes
sure that it gets the x-coordinate of
our spaceship let me just add a comment
so that you guys can understand get the
current x-coordinate of the spaceship so
it gets a current x-coordinate of the
spaceship and stores it inside this
variable bullet X and then it fires the
bullet using this bullet X variable and
this bullet Y variable basically which
we have said before that is 10 so we
want the bullet to move at the speed of
10 or change its Y value at every vile
iteration at
so after we do that it goes to this fire
bullet function and over there it
changes the state to fire and then it
creates that bullet after it changes a
state to fire it goes to this while loop
iteration and chain it says if bullet
State is fire and it keeps on firing the
bullet if we don't have this fire
underscore bullet statement then the
bullet won't appear on the screen so
anything that we want to be persisted
inside our game needs to be included
inside our while loop that is why we
have this function inside our while loop
if this statement was not there the
bullet wouldn't be dead
so that is why we need to make sure that
the bullet is continuously appearing on
the screen after every iteration of
while loop so after it fires a bullet
and it keeps on changing its
y-coordinate because of this statement
it happens
that it goes above the screen so after
it goes above the screen this if
condition is activated and it resets the
bullet to 480 y-coordinate and then it
resets the bullet stayed to ready again
and then we can suppress the spacebar
again and everything happens again
basically it's safe again the
x-coordinate of a spaceship but I'm not
going to go into all of that so guys
this is pretty much it for this video in
the next video we are going to create
multiple enemies so right now there is
only one enemy so it's very easy for our
spaceship or maybe depending upon what I
want and maybe I'm gonna teach you guys
how to shoot this nd so right now this
enemy can pass through the bullet and
nothing is happening to him so we are
gonna probably discuss that in the next
video
so in the last video we created multiple
bullets instead of shooting just one
bullet we can shoot multiple bullets at
the enemy and we don't have to you know
just just shoot one bullet during the
whole game but as you can see our bullet
is going through the enemy and it's not
colliding and nothing is happening when
the bullet hits the enemy not the score
is increasing and the enemy is also at
the same place it's not respawning
anywhere which we want so in this video
we are going to learn about the
collision concept how to make sure that
the two objects have collided and that's
a very important concept in gaming
so what we'll be doing is that let me
just actually load this game so that we
can see the bullet and the enemy
properly so what I'm gonna be doing is
we are gonna calculating the distance
between the bullet and the enemy and if
the distance is short enough then we are
conclusively say that the bullet has
collided so the bullet has an x and y
coordinates when it goes up through the
screen and similarly this enemy also has
an x and y coordinate when it goes
through the screen on left right or up
and down so we are gonna use all of
these four coordinates that is the x
coordinate and the x coordinate of our
bullets and the y coordinates of both
our bullet and an enemy to calculate the
distance between them so now what I want
you guys to do is go to Google and type
and distance between two coordinates and
you're going to take you to this website
match planet comm and over here there is
this equation which says distance equals
to x coordinate minus x coordinates of
other object squared plus y coordinate
of one object and y coordinate of other
object Square and then a square root of
the whole thing and this x2 and x1 does
not matter whatever is at front because
and by the end of the day we are
squaring this so obviously you must have
learned this in school or in college but
if you haven't don't worry about it just
go through this article a little bit you
just need to execute this code in this
equation in our Python so even if you
don't understand what this is doing we
are going to learn how to actually
implement our equation in Python so that
is going to be really helpful for you
guys so keep this equation and mine and
go back to our code and just believe
this fire underscore bullet function we
are going to create a new function and
we are gonna call it is coalition so
this function is basically going to help
us with define whether collision between
the bullet and an enemy has occurred or
not so he's gonna take four values the
x-coordinate of the enemy the
y-coordinate of the enemy the
x-coordinate of the bullet and similarly
the y coordinate of our bullet and now
we are going to create a variable known
as distance so this distance will store
the distance between the bullet and our
enemy and how do we calculate this
distance obviously using this equation
so distance equals two and then we are
gonna do a square root so to do a square
root or do any kind of mathematic
operations you need to import something
known as math so if you go up a hand
imported math yet so I'm just gonna
write import math so I'm going to import
that and then first of all we want to do
the square root so let me go over here
and just write math dot s qrt so this is
basically the function or the method for
doing square root and then apply some
brackets now we need the nvx and the
bullet X and we need to subtract it
according to the formula but before even
that we need to square it so if we go
back to our equation you can see after
the square root the x2 minus x1 is being
squared so we also need to implement
that mathematical formula so we are just
going to write Matt dot pee-eww so this
stands for power and then it requires
two values the X and the y so we are
going to do that so we are gonna just
write gamma two because we wanted to be
squared and then over here we are going
to give it the value of enemy X minus n
mu Y alright so this is looking good we
have executed the first part of our
equation now we have to execute the
second part of the equation that is plus
y2 minus y1 and the squared so we are
going to go back over here and inside
our math dot power so this is this part
math dot by x2 and this is enemy not
anyway why this is bullet X sorry about
that and then we are just going to write
plus and then we are going to write
dot pow again because we need another
power and requires two you know two
values first is the path value so we
want it to be squared again and then we
just need to subtract the enemy a when
you mean why so and me why - bullet why
and this should give us the value
obviously we need to close this meth
math door square root so we are going to
apply another bracket but looks like
it's an extra bracket so what we are
doing is math dot pow
we are doing X 2 minus X 1 or X minus X
1 minus X 2 doesn't matter squared it
and then math dot / y2 minus y1 squared
so just to make sure that these two are
separate we are going to apply another
bracket over here so I'm going to also
do this with this one let's not blonde
all right so there is some problem over
here so this is the problem so let's
apply a bracket oh yeah I just love that
and this is looking pretty good so now
what we are going to do is we are going
to write an if condition if this
distance is less than 27 pixels then
return us the value of true that as the
collision has occurred yes return us the
value of false so we're going to write F
condition and return false I mean we
didn't need to write this F condition we
could have just written false over here
but I just wanted to make sure that you
guys understood all right let's format
it properly obviously immunity for money
thing in pycharm make sure you press
ctrl or + L LS for I don't know
something so make sure you press ctrl
Alt + L if you are using PI job it
should format everything beautifully all
right so are s collision function is
complete so now what we are going to do
is we are going to scroll down and we
are going to write inside our while
infinite loop over here just below this
enemy X or even the politics we are
gonna add a comment that's gonna stand
for collisions so that we are know that
we are writing the code for collision
and over here we can just check whether
a collision or is happening or not so
I'm just going to create a variable
called causation and then I'm going to
call this s collision function and over
here we are going to set the
you of enemy X and if you buy and over
here in all of this code inside this
while loop we are manipulating the value
of x and y of enemy and the bullet so
this is the right place to call this
escalation function so over here we are
just going to write bullet X comma
bullet Y alright so this is looking good
so this is collision is going to store
the value of true and false and if the
collision has occurred is going to store
the value of collision of true in
collision all right so this is looking
good and then we are going to write a
condition if coalition so what do you
want us to do if the collision is
occurring basically that is what our
program is asking so what do you want
after a collision has occurred so the
first thing that we want is to reset the
bullet to its starting point so we are
going to reset the bullet wire at 480
and then because the bullet is not being
shown anymore we want to change the
state of the bullet to ready so let's
change the state of the bullet to ready
by writing bullet state equals to ready
and then the last thing we want to do is
obviously increase the score so I'm just
gonna create a new variable let's say
let's actually just go over here so that
it's close by and we are going to write
the value of score equals to zero
alright so this is looking pretty good
so I'm gonna just scroll down and over
here I'm gonna write score score by
missing the variable of score square
plus equals to 1.so this will increase
the value by one every time we hit our
enemy and after that we are just gonna
print out our score so I'm just gonna
print it out on the screen so now let's
just run our program and see if
everything is working or not so I'm just
gonna turn the main program and over
here we are going to shoot our bullets
and hopefully if it hits and I'm not a
bad player as you can see the score
increased by one so let's try to hit it
again and as you can see the score is
increasing by one but when we are not
hitting it the score is not increasing
so let's try to make our score at least
five or all right all right so the score
is five so what one thing you must have
noticed is that the enemy is still on
its current path and it's not respawning
to its default location so we need to
fix that so what we are going to do is
we are going to right change the value
player X the enemy X and the N mu by
over here so I'm just gonna scroll up
and check out where we have declared the
value of enemy X and eubiose so I'm just
gonna copy this and I'm gonna paste this
inside our if collision obviously like
this code can be optimized we can create
a new function for all of this stuff
that is happening over here but maybe we
can do that in the later videos all the
optimization classes and functions we
will see whether we do that or not
because this is not such a complicated
program but maybe we do that so now what
will happen is that the enemy X and the
enemy wire will get restarted or respond
to a different location and will respond
to a random integer that is between zero
to 800 and Y is 50 to 150 obviously we
already discussed what this does it
basically gives a default position to
the enemy so let's give it a shot again
and we're gonna run the mean again and
see if it works so let me just wait for
it all right so our enemy is actually
just going back to its new location all
right let's just wait for the enemy to
come back a little bit down so that we
know that our code is working properly
so let's shoot it all right so our game
is respawn probably our enemies respawn
properly and it looks good so one thing
you might have noticed that when it
comes to this right-hand side of the
screen it just drops down even if you
are trying it on your own if an enemy
respawns towards the right-hand side of
that window of a window it just goes
down so why is that happening that is
happening because when we respawn our
enemy or just be when you are creating
then we are giving it a value of 0 to
800 and but inside our code we have
written in over here that if the enemy X
is greater than 736 make sure you change
its Y value so therefore whenever our
enemy is responding with a greater value
than 736 it's immediately going down
without a chance to go left that's why
we need to make sure that over here when
we are creating the enemy that we do not
increase the value till 800 only
7:36 and just for safety we are going to
write 735 so obviously we need to make
sure that the 735 also goes in when a
collision has occurred so I'm just gonna
copy that away - all right so this looks
good we have also fixed an error so this
is looking pretty good all right so all
right look enemies respawning properly
let me just shoot it again all right
so alright guys so this is pretty much
it for this video in the next video we
are gonna learn how to create multiple
enemies so right now there is only one
enemy so the game is pretty easy you can
just play it really easy and actually
it's pretty fun to play when I'm
recording this video I'm also playing
but anyway guys let me just recap
actually quickly so that you guys can
understand so if you already understand
the video just go to the next video but
for people who have not understood
probably so we have created a function
called s collision where you have 4
coordinates to off enemy coordinates and
to of bullet coordinates and we have
used all of these four coordinates in
this formula which we got from typing in
distance between two coordinates this
formula and then we try to execute this
formula inside our code obviously before
you shall start doing this man thought
squad make sure that you import math and
after that we made the square root and
then inside this week using the dot
power function we squared it just like
we have done in this formula X 2 minus X
square squared so we needed to make sure
that we squared it and make sure that
the brackets are correctly placed
because if you guys are typing the code
it might like it might you might mess up
somewhere so make sure you guys are
typing this code properly line by line
all right obviously I upload all this
Corp on github so you'll find it
somewhere over there and by the end of
the series I will upload it after
recording all the video so you can wait
for it a little bit or you can find it
in the description or attachments or
something so Matt dot power enemy X -
politics you guys understand all of this
stuff and then how this 27 number came
to be so I just tried and tested what
was the proper number for distance
between enemy and bullet to call it a
coalition hand
just by trial and testing I came on this
number if the distance between the
bullet and the enemy is less than 27 I'm
gonna call it a collision and then if
the collision has occurred it will
return true and obviously we are calling
this function over here
if collision so if a collision has
occurred what do we want from a program
first of all we want to reset the Y of
doublet to 480 that is the starting
position of the spaceship and then we
are going to change the state of course
to ready because you can't see the
bullet anymore and when you can't see
the bullet anymore the state is ready
and then we increase the score by 1 and
we printed out the score and then we
made sure that the enemy respawn to its
new location all right guys so this is
basically a way to just to track back a
little bit this is just a way to kill
the enemy and then make sure that we
also create a new enemy all right guys
this is pretty much it for this video
thank you for hanging out in the next
video we are going to learn how to
create multiple enemies so I'll see you
over there
in this video we are gonna learn how to
create multiple enemies and in the
previous video we learned how about how
the collision system works so for
example if you shoot the enemy is going
to respond to a new place as well as
increase our score so how do we make
sure that multiple enemies appear on a
screen so for example six enemies so
what we can do one idea is that we can
store all of these six enemies in a list
or an array but an add-on is called a
list so we are going to store all of the
enemies in a list and display them one
by one on the screen but it's going to
happen so far that it will look that all
the six enemies are appearing
simultaneously on the screen so we are
going to turn all of these variable into
a list variable and how do you do that
you simply copy the variable name and
equal to and brackets so this signifies
an empty list there is nothing inside
this list and we are going to use a for
loop to put values inside this list but
we have to do it with all of the
variables so let's do that
so let's do it with enemy X and then
enemy Y so I'm just copy this copy this
paste over here let me just copy
everything first and then I'm gonna add
the square brackets not the neatest way
but the quickest way and then I'm just
gonna copy all of these square brackets
quickly alright and how do you add
values inside a list so right now this
is an empty list and how do you add
values to a list is by using a method
known as dot append so instead of equals
to we are gonna use dot append over here
but even before that we are going to
create a variable known as the num of
enemies which stands for number of
enemies and you can change this variable
whenever we want to increase the number
of enemies so we are going to create a
for loop for I in range and inside this
we are gonna put number of enemies so
this loop for right now is gonna run six
times and six of our enemies are going
to be created obviously we want all of
these values to be added to the list
that we have created of all the
variables so what we are going to do
instead of two equal to we are going to
write dot append and this is going to
add our current value inside our list so
for example the first enemy image is
going to be stored inside this enemy
image list so we are not doing all of
this with all of the
Able's and you don't need to do it with
any by a change because these are like
constant values but whether I just for
the sake of simplicity we are going to
do it with all of them alright so let me
just do it because all of them I'm going
to copy this dot append everywhere so
just to do it quickly again not the
neatest way but the quickest way and
that is what we want just the quickest
way and let me just add the blackest
after every one so that there are no
errors and it looks neat
alright guys so this is looking pretty
well so whenever a code is going to run
it's going to go through this and it's
going to create six number of enemies
but if we scroll down inside our while
loop you can see that we don't specify
which enemy x do we want to move so this
is the code that we are using for the
enemy to move towards the left hand side
or the right hand side and the downward
movement but if we don't specify which
enemy X we are talking about because if
you notice above we have declared six NV
x and because we have created a variable
called as enemy x we have created an
empty list so each time this fall dupage
quran' is going to enter a new value of
enemy x inside this enemy x list so we
need to make sure that our program
understands which enemy x we are talking
about so we are going to create another
for loop over here and we are going to
do the same thing that we did over there
number of enemies and the idea is pretty
intuitive if you just need to change
every value over here to basically
inside a square bracket just specify
which value you are talking about and
this is a way to reference something
inside a list obviously if you know less
you probably already know about this so
anyways we are going to do this we are
going to I this I bracket everywhere so
let me just copy and paste this
everywhere so that our program knows
which anyway we are talking about which
enemy Y change we are talking about let
me just copy this everywhere all right
this is looking pretty good and then we
also need to make sure that a collision
is also inside our enemy so we are going
to copy all of this code from over here
and we are going to place this inside
our while loop because we need to make
sure that we calculate the collision for
every let meter
face this so you can see over here that
currently our collision is it's not in
sight or for loop but actually inside
yeah it's actually inside our follow but
make sure that it's not inside this LF
condition or the if condition otherwise
it's not gonna work a lot of people make
this mistake that they don't pace the
collision part correctly or don't pace
anything properly so anyways after
making sure that you have pasted it's
probably inside her for loop we are also
gonna change these let me just press
ctrl-z
you are going to make sure that python
program knows which NEX coordinates we
are talking about so let me just paste
this over here alright so this is
looking pretty good we also need to make
sure that we add I over here
so basically wherever we are talking
about the enemy or the coalition you
need to make sure that a program knows
which coordinate or which enemy we are
talking about and then the last thing we
need to do is whether we are calling the
enemies for example over here calling
the enemy function and this is where
we're basically bleeding the enemy we
also need to make sure that we add which
image do we want to be plated so right
now it's not specifying so we are going
to paste this inside our enemy for loop
and make sure is not post pasted inside
the if condition its pasted inside our
loop so intend Asian's matter and then
we are going to send the value of I
according with specifying which x and y
coordinates we want to be plated on the
screen so basically which and maybe we
are talking about so if we go up to our
enemy function over here you can see we
haven't specified the aya values so we
need to specify the hank value and also
the which image enemy image do we want
to draw obviously you will be thinking
there is only one image but actually
there are six enemy images because we
have created a list of enemy images too
as you can see over here alright guys so
this is looking pretty good I think
almost all of the core is done so let me
just play it and then we will figure out
what we have to recap and if there are
any errors we can solve them so let's
play it and see if it works all right so
this is looking pretty good we have
created six enemies and when we showed
them so let's try and sure
of them I'm such a bad player alright so
many we are shooting them our collision
is also working it's they are respawning
alright so this is looking pretty good
so how is this game gonna hand whenever
one of these space invaders come and hit
the bottom of the spaceship or basically
hit the 480 y-axis then we are going to
end the game so we will just keep
shooting and increase the score and
right now there is no place where we are
displaying this course in the next video
we are going to make sure that we
display the score on the left hand side
corner
alright guys welcome back so in the last
video we created multiple enemies and
our game is looking real real good so
the score system is working but the
score is not being currently displayed
on our game window so we'll fix that in
this video we'll make sure that the
score appears on the top-left corner of
our screen so how do you do that so that
is simple we use the font object that is
inside my game so my game is actually
going to help us create fun or text on
the screen so the first thing we need to
do is go to this bullet image and we are
going to actually remove the score
variable that we've created over here so
instead of that we are going to just
press ENTER and write score so that we
know we are creating score under this
statement and then right now we are
going to create a variable known as core
value and we're gonna give it value of 0
and obviously you can see with this red
symbol there is some error which say
score +1 we are doing it over here so we
need to change this to score value and
then we can you remove the print
statement because we don't need it now
so let's just go up now and then we have
to use the score object or the by
GameSpot object so that is pretty easy
you just create a variable known as fund
and obviously you probably know already
what font is font is just the type of
text or the style of text that is
displayed how much the width of the line
often is is actually dependent upon the
font what kind of font you use so first
we are going to define what kind of font
do we want so how do you do that we just
use the PI game dot font method that is
inside PI game buying game dot font dot
capital F font and inside this we are
going to give it two values the first
cyst which Vaughn do we want
so inside PI again there is one free
font which is known as free sans bold so
right now we are just going to use this
font and dot T TF is the extension of
the font and then we are going to give
it a size so we are just going to give
it a size of 32 and then after that we
are going to give it the X&Y coordinates
of where we want this text to appear so
we wanted to appear in the top left
corner somewhere but not
attach the screen a little bit away from
the screen so we are going to give it a
value of text text the x-coordinate of
ten pixels and then text Y of that is
the y-coordinate also of ten now just
like we did with these player play
enemies we have to create a function
that going to show this core value on
the screen so let's do that
we are going to create a function which
we are gonna call shows code pretty easy
stuff and inside this function we have
to give it the X and my values just like
we have 10 bits everything else and one
difference is that for example you can
see how we are plating the image inside
this def player instead of letting the
player drawing the player on the screen
we are going to render the text on the
screen so so I will show you what I mean
by that so we are going to create a
variable of score and inside this we are
going to write font dot render and you
gonna require some values inside it so
this is the what I mean by instead of
blading we are going to render the text
or show the text on the screen so using
this font object we have created over
here we are gonna write phone to
on-trend oh and then is gonna require a
couple of values the first value is what
text do you want so we want our text to
be first of all score and then we want
the score value in front of the text so
we are gonna write in actually we have
to convert it into a string so right now
this score value is an integer so we
have to use typecasting and inside this
so basically we are converting this
integer value to a string by writings
STR in front of it this concept in
python is known as type casting and
actually in programming this concept is
known as typecasting so inside this we
are going to write score value and then
after that the second value is requires
is true so we can display it on the
screen and then the third value it
requires is what is the color of font
that you want you can show whatever
color you want obviously we have to use
the RGB values which we have discussed
before but I am just going to use the
white color that is 255 red
five green and then 255 blue so this is
looking pretty good let me just format
this properly and then we are going to
show it on the screen and how do you
show it on the screen so first we are
going to render this code or render the
text and then we have to plate this text
on the screen or draw this text on the
screen that is why I said this is a
little bit different first you have to
render then you have completed on the
screen so we are going to use the same
concept we have over here so actually
let me just copy this from here and
paste it and instead of image we are
going to render our scone so this time
is not an image it's a font or a text
and it requires x and y value which we
are providing through this function and
now one last step that we have to do is
pretty easy we just have to go down and
anything that you want to persist on a
screen obviously has to be called inside
our while loop so I'm just going to call
our show score function and X Y is text
X and text Y all right guys so this is
looking pretty easy so let me just run
it and show you that it works and
hopefully it will run without any errors
so our score is big displayed on the top
left corner and when we shoot someone
let me just show someone as you can see
our score is increasing so let me just
shoot a couple of more enemies of space
invaders all right guys so this is
looking pretty good a score is
increasing and users are being respawn
and a game is being created so one last
thing I want to tell you guys is that
how do you add extra font so right now
if we go to our font so for example here
is a port this is the only phone that is
inside our PI game so let me just close
this how do you add other fonts inside
this so what you can do is you can go to
a website or something and download
fonts and they will give you a phone
that is of extension dot TTFN and you
can just download this place it inside
your project structure and just write
the name of the font so for example what
you can do is you can go to this website
known as Li da font and this gives a lot
of fonts for free so you can download
just any a thing form that you want and
we're going to give you a zip file just
extract that zip file and it's gonna
give you a dot TTL file then paste that
TTF file inside
Space Invader project folder and just
write the name over here and then you
can use that font inside your PI game so
this is pretty easy and this stands for
the font size so let me just increase
her first sign to something crazy 70
maybe it's not that crazy but as you can
see the score has increased to 70 cents
but let's keep it let's see if it small
32 pixels alright guys so this is pretty
much it so let just to recap for a
little bit first we created the score
value we added a fond object then we
created the X&Y coordinates of the font
where we wanted to appear and then
inside a source code we did two things
we rendered the font and then we lit it
or trick it on the screen and render we
applied or give it three values the
score the true and the color of our text
so you can change it to green so let me
just show you - you guess
RGB so GB should be 255 and then we can
should make both of these values as 0
red and blue and this should make it
green let's play it and as you can see
it's green but we want to invite color
white I think looks good on any game so
let me just change it to 255 again
alright let me just give a space over
here and then we drew it on the screen
and then the last thing we did was
before changing the value of our score
so after collision we need to make sure
that the score value is increasing by 1
after we hit the red mean by a bullet
and the second thing is we call the show
underscore function that is pretty
standard alright guys so in the next
video we are going to learn how to end
the game so right now the game is not
ending is just keeping on going even if
the enemy hits our spaceship so one
thing I notice is that the enemies are
not moving very fast so we will also
increase the speed of the enemy a little
bit in the next video and we'll make
these minor changes so I'll see you over
there
alright guys welcome back and hopefully
you are having a great day and today we
are going to learn about how to add
sounds and music to our PI game and
currently there are no sounds inside our
game so it looks pretty simple but what
we are going to do is we are going to
add three types of sounds the first
sound is the background song that's
going to play continuously in the
background the second is the shooting of
the bullet sound in this case I call it
laser dot wave and the third one is
explosion dot wave that is going to be
produced by in our laser bullet hits our
enemy and just to show you guys how it
sounds I'm gonna play this main dot
Python file which I've already changed
the code off so that you guys can see
what's happening inside of game so I'm
just gonna play it and you can see
all right so you must have seen there
are three sounds first sound
continuously goes in the background
second is the laser or the bullet sound
and the third is when our bullet hits
our enemy now how can you get all these
three files let me actually make sure
that the code is original and the last
one that we have used and now how do you
get these three dot WAV files so what I
want you to guys to do is I want you to
go to github.com a3 about space invaders
by game and you will be able to get all
the code that I have written till now
and along whether you will be able to
get the dot WAV files that I have been
talking about after downloading these
three files or maybe the whole code and
you can download them by clicking on
this clone or download and then download
zip make sure you add these sound files
to your project by going to space
invader and just pasting them over there
now let's get started with adding
background music into our game so first
thing we need to do is import something
known as a mixer from a PI game library
and to do that we just right from my
game import mixer input this mixer and
what does this mixer this is basically a
class that helps us handle all kind of
music inside our game whether it can be
repeating our music loading a music
anything that you want so you have to
look inside this class whenever you want
to do anything with sounds or music and
then just below this background we are
going to add a background sound so let's
right come inside so that you guys can
know in future what we are talking about
and then we're just gonna use the mixer
library by writing mixer dot music dot
load pretty easy because you want to
load the file and then we are going to
play the file and inside this we are
just going to write background dot wave
which is the name of our file as you can
see on the left hand side and then we
are just gonna play this sound by
writing mixer dot music play play easy
and now we want this file to play
continuously because right now if we
don't add anything inside this dot play
this file is gonna play once and then
just stop but we want it to play in a
loop because this is a game and can go
on for long we don't want it to play
just once and how do you do that inside
this mixer class you just add minus one
and is gonna play on Lou so now let's
just test it out and see whether it's
working or not
[Music]
as you can hear the background music
must be going on but we haven't yet
added the bullet sound explosion sound
so that must not be there so that's why
we are gonna be working on adding the
bullets on now but one thing I want you
guys to notice is that currently we are
using mixer dot music because we want
this file to be played continuously in
the background so this is kind of music
but if something is very short for
example our bullet sound then we have to
use mixer dot sound so we also going to
come below where we have a bullet
shooting so how are you going to catch
the moment where our bullet is being
released so we are going to do that
inside our let's go to above let's go to
this if bullet state is ready
so over here we can release the sound of
our bullet going out from our spaceship
so because over here we are getting the
x-coordinate of the spaceship and then
we are shooting the bullet over here so
we can somewhere over here at our
bullets tongue and how do you do that is
also pretty easy just below this we are
going to write mixer dot sound so in
this case it's not mixer dot music it's
mixer add sound and we gonna first
create available let's create a variable
and call it bullet underscore a sound
just to make sure that we know where our
sound is and mixer dots on and inside
this you have to give the file of the
sound so in that in our case is laser
dot wave and then just like we did in
the music case we are gonna play it so
we're just gonna write but it's sound
not state well its sound dot play and we
don't want it to be played inside loop
that's why we haven't added minus one so
now our bullets is making a sound now we
just need to add a sound to our
collation and where are we catching
collision let me just copy this first
and we are gonna go below I just want
you to guess first where we are going
because this is pretty obvious we are
going to this part where if collision we
want a sound P played and that sound is
of explosion so we are just gonna copy
and paste this over here because most of
the things are going to be same instead
of bullet we are gonna write explosion
sound and then I'm just gonna copy and
paste this just below this play and
instead of laser dot wave we are gonna
go with explosion dot wave so this this
is pretty much it
let's actually play our game one more
time and see if everything is working
properly
so let's play this
[Music]
[Music]
all right guys so everything is looking
really good so are all of the three
sounds are playing obviously feel free
to work around and play around and add
more sounds maybe remove and add your
own sons that's going to be fun
in the next video we are going to learn
about how to make sure that our game
gets over when our enemy hits our
spaceship so I'll see you over there
in the last video we learned how to add
sounds to our game and in this video we
are going to show the game over screen
so I removed all of these sounds for
this video because it's going to be
difficult to explain what's going on if
I add the sum so what we are going to do
is when many of these enemies come close
to our spaceship maybe tilt over here
we're going to remove all of these
enemies or maybe just get them out of
the screen and we are going to show a
big test just like we have shown over
here the score 0 we are going to show a
big text of game over over here in the
middle of the screen and finish this
pixel is going ahead when are these
enemies gonna come close to the
spaceship when they are going to hit the
y-axis of 440 pixels so if you remember
at the top at 0 pixel at the bottom is
600 pixel and I just add the starting of
the spaceship it's about 480 pixel but
just by experimenting I have found out
that 440 is perfect so we're gonna use
that for 40 pixel as a limit so winner
and means come over here we are going to
show game over for our player and the
final score is going to be shown over
here so what we are gonna do is we are
going to come to our Emmys where we are
moving our enemies basically so we are
going to come down and come to enemy
movement so enemy movement was over here
and then over here we are just gonna add
our text so let's add a text and just
call it game over because we are going
to be reading the game over codes just
below this and what we want is whenever
an enemy
let's enemy why and whenever enemy y of
I so whenever one of the enemies it
doesn't need to be all of the enemies
when one of the enemies come to 440
pixels and actually just to test it out
I don't want that needs to come to the
bottom so I'm going to make it very very
small maybe to 200 pixels and just when
we are ending the game and we are
finalizing the game I am going to change
it okay into for 40 pixels so whenever
one of the enemies come to 200 pixels
then what we want to do we want to move
on the enemies so we are going to create
another for loop for J in and then we
just gonna copy all of these because we
want to move all the enemies out of the
screen that's why I am going to create
and the for loop inside this big follow
and then under this and is going to
change the access of NV Y J equals to
2000
and this should make sure that these
enemies go below the screen to 2,000 by
pixel and then after this I'm gonna just
make sure that we display the game over
text so how do you do that I'm gonna
create a function and this function will
be called underscore game over text and
we are going to call this function and
then we are going to break out of this
loop so let make sure that we are not
doing anything weird with the brackets
and over here we are just gonna write
brick and this looks pretty good so what
we are doing is whenever of enemy it
turns need to be all the enemies when
one of the enemies reaches this greater
than 200 pixels in this case but it's
actually going to be 440 and then we are
gonna collect all of the enemies inside
this follow and we want each of the
enemies to be moved out of the screen
and we are doing that by setting the
y-axis to 2000 this is not going to be
shown on the screen
and then we are calling this game over
text function which is going to display
their game over text on the screen and
then we are breaking out of this loop
because we don't need this for I in
range loop anymore so now let's create
this game over underscore test functions
so we are going to go where we have
added our score so let's just go over
here so you can see we have added our
score over here so we are going to do
doing basically the escapes same thing
and we're gonna write game over text
over here and then we are gonna copy the
same thing that we have done over here
and instead of font we are going to just
write game or maybe we can write over
underscore font and we want this font to
be bigger so this is the size of the
font we are gonna made it 64 by 64
pixels the size is bigger and then we
are going to create our function so just
below this show underscore function we
are going to create our game over text
function and we are going to do the same
thing that we did previously with our
show underscore function and then over
here let's just copy and paste this line
so we are gonna copy this paste over
here and then instead of score let's
just call it over underscore text and
then we do need all of this stuff we
just need to be displayed game and let's
make it in capitals just make sure it
looks good game over so
is looking good then we just need to
blitt it on truant on the screen so
we're gonna copy and paste this over
here let's just press ENTER and paste
this over here and this instead of score
we are gonna write over underscore text
and we are not because we are not going
to use the x and y values we can use it
but because our gamers takes is going to
be displayed at one place so I'm gonna
remove this and instead of that I am
just gonna write 200 250 pixels and this
200 comma 250 pixel is basically the
middle of the screen you can try out
different values and see what works for
you but basically I have divided both of
these values by 2 and made it a little
bit less both the X and y-axis and
that's how I got to the center obviously
you to change the values a little bit so
that it looks good anyway so this is
looking pretty good right now let's run
our mean dot file and see if it's
working and you have to remember that we
have made it 200 pixels and you can see
that our grain vortex is being displayed
but it's not in the middle and it's not
big so why is that happening and this is
because we have used the same font over
here that we have created previously
this font we need to change this and
because we have created a new font that
is known as the oaf on so we're just
gonna copy this and paste this instead
of font on trend up we are gonna paste
over underscore font because this is our
new font and this point for used for a
score that's why it's so small
now let's reload it and hopefully this
time it will work so let's wait for it
to come to 200 y-axis and after that
it's gonna show the game over screen so
now you can't hit any of the enemies so
the score is going to remain the
constant so let me just show it to you
again let me just hit a couple of
enemies and now we have hit our enemies
so let's wait for our 200 pixel to get
over and it's gonna happen anytime soon
alright so it's showing game over and
now because we can't hit any more
enemies your score is going to remain
constant obviously you can add more
buttons like play again and do stuff
like that but by now you already know
how to do it so I'm not going to go into
it again so now finally let's change is
now that we know what that our code is
working instead of 200 let's change it
to 440 pixels and make sure you add the
sounds again and make it a complete game
so guys this is pretty much it for this
video series we created our space
invader
from scratch and if you were a big know
who didn't know anything about my game
or creating games now you have a basic
understanding of how a game is created
it has been wonderful hanging out with
you guys so thank you for watching and
I'll see you around